in making an IMAX theatre film because
the medium is so different than every
other media new vantage points like from
the air or from underwater become much
more critical to you it's a very serious
trip were going on in freezing waters up
the Arctic Ocean one of the first things
we had to do when they boarded the ship
was go through a safety briefing and how
to put on a survival suit if you fell in
the water without the survival suit
you'd be dead in three minutes
hypothermia would set in that's it we're
very close to the North Pole on this
expedition it's getting colder in a
second
when you're filming sharks you're often
putting bait in the water when you go
out and jump in front of a bear and he's
swimming towards you I I kind of guessed
you are the bait so that's kind of a
different perspective did your black
seal suit out there polar bears are much
better swimmers I wish could swim as
fast as a polar bear they're good
swimmers but they're not good divers
fortunately I was a good sinker and when
bears did come down and show interest I
could just push my camera up to them and
keep sinking and then they change their
mind and go back to the surface so that
worked good I never really felt like I
was that much in danger by the Bears I
felt comfortable as long as the water
was you know fairly deep
the walrus is over there and to the left
there in that little valley yeah we just
found a Waldo sort of water so hopefully
you will come over and say hello to us I
really was impressed with the walruses I
thought they were just beautiful
walruses are good divers I mean then
they move fast in the water they look so
clunky and not very comfortable on land
but when they get in the water they
really in their element we got great
footage of a whole walrus colony and one
shot in particular and the walrus and
this baby went straight up to the camera
basically kissed the camera and then
came back up that's a kind of crazy
amazing rewarding thing about wildlife
filmmaking is being able to get it when
you have all the right variables at the
same time you hardly ever have that
opportunity but when you do it's so
rewarding
you